what is going on there citizens the
reject Nation Greg and Sally are
returning
for a sequel reaction to I wanted to say
this smoother it did not go as according
to plan Pitch Perfect 2 is what we want
to watch today Pitch Perfect Two now
last time Sally was visiting California
she's back in the heart of NYC right now
um you know so she can't be here but
she's here doing what Mary Jane does
best you and Mary Jane does best guys go
check out the trailer for her Mary Jane
short film she is hard at work plugging
away at the editing system whipping
other people into shape to get it done
go ahead support it it's the way to go
about life Sally are you excited for
Pitch Perfect 2. I don't think anyone is
as excited as you are guys Greg is so
hyped for this I've never seen he's more
excited about this than like John Wick
yeah okay a little bit more sad about
this than actually having neck Keanu
Reeves I'm more excited for this than
anything else yes that's right guys you
know what to do be a perfect reject by
leaving a like that mean the world also
uh subscribe and click that notification
Bell notify when our reaction for Pitch
Perfect 3 is that we gotta complete the
trilogy don't we Sally don't we yes we
do yep full trilogy
and also massive thank you to all who
followed our patreon via the first Pitch
Perfect movie
um as always full-length Reaction watch
logs where you sync up with your own
copy it Pitch Perfect 2 available for a
super sexy rejects exclusively however
we do cover stuff exclusively over there
as well all right salamander you ready
to kick in action or whatever the phrase
is
um
so ready let's do it
[Music]
should we do vocal warm-ups too
red leather yellow leather
[Applause]
than sitting here to my left is Gail
labrinathy mccadden Fine Burger this
one's gonna stick John well you saved
the Jew for last
didn't she direct this one I think so
now here they are performing for the
president of the United States on his
birthday wow
that's actually Obama and Michelle Obama
what
[Music]
oh my God
Rebecca Mitchell leader of the group
look at these sequins she's already
dancing Becca's the official leader is
that blonde [__] gone
yeah I guess so close
having a great time that's insane I'm
still not over that
she may have to do that backflip right
back over the fence into Mexico I think
she's going
oh
yes an overweight girl dangling from the
ceiling who hasn't had that dream
[Music]
why do I feel like there's an accident
about to happen I feel it too
I'm nervous yep
there's no underwear on we have a
Commando situation
she's turning brace yourself
oh no no no no no no no no nobody wants
to
oh that's rough Amy
Amy a birthday gift from Down Under
during last night's Night Celebration
chip I'm talking about her
she showed her Virginia to the president
I love that guy's reaction accident
although authorities have ruled out
terrorism as a motive
it's a National Disgrace yeah but I'd
rather be in that limo ride home with
the president cut to the real president
he'd be like that [__] was off the hook
[Laughter]
I like vaginas Obama impression
not vagina
this is terrible
it reminds me of feds from That 70s Show
but like a girl version unfortunately an
example must be made it is
suspended what it was an accident like
no one did it on purpose who's in the
National Anthem at the Puppy Bowl a
German group of total professors
in other words they're going to keep
their pants on sons of [__] so
basically the Bellas are over
[Laughter]
it's so true Sally
Steinfeld are her shoes in this oh yeah
I listen to her music and
hands competition it's not gonna help
your case here not at all what if we win
it what if you win it
I feel like
[Music]
what if you win it yeah if we win will
you reinstate us sure what no American
team has ever won oh this is about
fighting for America they're gonna win
oh
the world
Jesus loves her she wants more
[Music]
they don't care what songs they sing I
was gonna say like if this were a real
University like they would be getting me
in front of so bad right now like people
be yelling stuff I know it someone
dropped some bass
[Music]
I'll be the burrito
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Music]
wow they could never win
again they're so good they are very good
that's great news yes
no I can start Monday I'm I would be
stupid what are you thinking I want 100
commitment and laser focus right great I
will see you Monday now Becca hi
Benjamin Applebaum At Your Service I
just have to say you are so spirited I I
just want to put you in a box and saw
you in half nice
as a part of a trick but oh yeah that's
right he's a magic he's the magic boy I
was out of context that was weird dude
why do I feel so guilty I'm giving a lot
to the Bellas right it's like three
years of my life yeah back you should
not feel guilty at all about taking your
shot this this is a big deal right yes
no Becca support a boyfriend did he dye
his hair
it looks darker
and the age of the internet you're
better off just staying with the
acapella group really you think so are
you doing a British accent yeah I don't
know why I don't I don't know why people
who has to help Frank watch YouTube
videos to find the next Justin Bieber oh
it's Keegan Michael Key yay I love him
that is the legendary Snoop Dogg then
now he wants to drop his own cool
Christmas album what I need all hands on
deck right now to come up with ideas on
how to make this one stand out come on
Becca let's see why you left the Bellas
she's like we could remix
[Laughter]
your mother is Catherine junk word is
she has a five octave vocal range you do
not want to hear that woman doing it
with my dad
hey got Anna Kendrick and Haley
Steinfeld in the same movie
when tomorrow comes I'll be on my own
being in front of the things that I
don't know when tomorrow comes and no
the road is long I look up to the sky
Darkness all around no that one I'm not
I'm still kind of tinkering with ever so
it's not nothing's really completely
said
you are my flashlight
would you excuse us for just one second
what are they gonna do I'm nervous for
her I don't think we should decide
anything without big
any under my tongue
I didn't hear what she said
welcome to the valley
whoa oh girl stop sorry
my first college party this is acapella
only yeah to get prepared to meet a lot
of sexually confuse me
[Laughter]
I thought she was with you
right Craig slogan
he's so cute
the movies
are you asking me out
yes
hey Chloe asked where you were
why didn't you tell her she's like
locked into the world right now and I'm
looking for the right time I'll tell her
Bumper's back
no one cares
[Laughter]
I don't know what you're thinking oh
Pampa you shut your face and kiss me
[Music]
please just shut up he's doing Gollum
my precious
I can't believe we're sisters Chloe
texted me we added a legacy I didn't
even know that was a thing Becca
you better get your priorities straight
got work to do and you only got one shot
You Gotta Sing For America and for every
other country in the competition
oh my god oh no
[Music]
control
s
oh my God yeah they've already started
out with quite a bang
oh this is pretty cool
[Music]
this is good yeah it's like the
Terminator
of vocabulary
thought we gonna compete with a group
that size they're so freaking insane
yeah their choreography is crazy
[Applause]
[Music]
I do love this song it's a great song
check you out before the world where
we're going to
it is or is it a fairies she played an
elf and had one movie you are like a
troll
she was in trouble oh she was in trolls
and now I really must go rest my neck
it is
I'm gonna use that we're gonna beat DSM
at their own game do what they do
important thing is
uh come on
uh
why do I feel like Amy's like meaner in
this movie pretty sure they made her up
did they explain what happened to the
blonde girl no was she older than the
other ones did she just graduate
and I feel like they should explain it
yeah
sexual this time jeez I was
pointers Maybe
exactly where you're gonna put me into
the songs I just have somewhere that I
need to be you know what that felt rude
that did feel like I felt that in my
soul yeah I was very upset
[Music]
I was not excited
there's nothing nothing special about it
yet you know what I mean hear me out
please Dax please remove the sleigh
bells
and put in
Kalimba
um just have him sing it again the same
way who are you nobody literally nobody
I just had a thought
what is the idea
she's gonna mess with the beat a
beautiful side we're happy tonight
see I told you she was gonna remix it
that's her thing damn she's actually
doing a really good job
[Music]
oh [__]
this sounds great yeah good thing she
knows the song
Santa Claus
I want this on my Christmas playlist You
Belong With The Palace Greg you are so
upset about this it's great you
know yeah I'm like a three-time
Collegiate acapella Champion so
wow
Dax turn around right now and and watch
this exchange
[Applause]
that's so funny she did something that
was helpful and now I'm going to reward
her
but we've got an idea me too water skis
but for dry land Real Player you know
what I'm talking about brilliant
looks like we've been invited to sing at
some kind of a party well there's just
an address and a password how sexy and
mysterious
teeth they're from other people
what did she say
can you turn it up I get all my teeth
from other people password
fart noise
oh my gosh there's so many famous people
in this yeah
this is the big
time holy [__] oh wow the curtains are
soundproof
[Music]
the World building in this movie
the lore
it's like chocolate
expanded
first we have the troublemakers oh is
this like a new version of the riff-off
yeah probably like a weird like culty
version
they're back yeah he joined them
the Green Bay Packers
what all right all right when I point to
you you sing a song from one of the
categories it's going to appear up there
on the big board you have to meet the
beat Turn the Beat over
but you have to do it Follow the Leader
Style
[Laughter]
song
[Music]
[Applause]
that is not his voice
[Music]
[Applause]
boots
[Music]
can you handle this I don't think they
can handle this I don't think you're
ready
[Music]
let me have it let us have it let the
world
how about them Cowboys
[Music]
a wheel drive everyone knows this one
yes
[Music]
what the hell no he was so hyped
couldn't have done Love Story by Taylor
Swift
Just awk appointment
now we're doing Taylor Swift
[Music]
nice getting together you'll go talk to
your friends talk to my friends
[Music]
[Laughter]
this person dated John Mayer I'm
confused yeah
[Applause]
they better have some Cameo at the end
of Tina Turner and John Mayer that would
be funny
oh oh they lose now so they can win
later
oh nice nice
here we go
to the membrane
[Music]
sorry what 90s hip-hop Jam is that again
she has a small palette
a 21st century Jam that's it yeah I
wrote it why would she do that you are
sabotaging the Bellas the Bellas you
[__]
in light of this embarrassing and
unprofessional information I am forced
to declare
[Music]
oh but maybe they can win later by doing
Originals
thinking like that song sounded familiar
to me it definitely
I think it's a big song
I'm just kidding would you like to have
sex later no no
yeah I did this dead air between us is a
good sign
and what you gave me was more mashups
but if you want to write music producer
on your tax form someday then you've got
to have an original voice look Rebecca
what is it Becca I'm Richard
everybody else in here is an intern
you're talented everybody else in here
is talented so what the hell makes you
special you know what I mean he's like
the epitome of how L.A makes you feel
show me who you are as an artist okay
oh my God you're calling Haley write
something original yeah talk about your
parents divorce do The Cup Song again
that's a cover no it's not she did it
via a cover
[Music]
[Laughter]
I feel like Jesse's barely present in
this movie yeah what
fun to know as I enter the rest of my
life oh you're the most talented person
that I know and I've met three of The
Wiggles
no way what do I gotta do to get that
you gotta become more
Sally become more just more of a become
more become more flash my badge in front
of the president
couple oh wow that's so cute that's rare
that you hook up with a guy and then he
wants to date it doesn't happen you stop
sleeping around Sally I have
can you name one bumper and I'll name
one Fat Amy and yours will be bigger
bigger than it'll be cute and we could
put him on our bed that we share he's
going too far but he he has a person is
too far you know
hurt me go back to how things used to be
and go at it or on top of all this
expensive food that I bought are you
crying
tied down by anything
you know you feel sad no
nope just for a bunch of old people you
got me so much
is this for the crowd the right crowd
um
[Music]
who are you performing for I know like
what honestly my senses are overwhelmed
here John you might want to tone down
the theatrics let's hope there are no
props
like
[Music]
oh my God
now they lit one on fire oh good heavens
[Music]
this is what happens when you send girls
to college
is it one of the things
are we the apples burnt to death because
you occupations because he was standing
in the wrong spot no float flipped into
me blame that Minority I'm black gay and
a woman
[Music]
this legacy's fault me obviously we're
not going to beat docile machine at
their game so we need a new plan like
now original music I think the retreat
will be a good thing you girls need to
bond heading into Worlds it'll be so
much fun I don't know no Mom it's bad or
bring her back I'll never get this so
low at Lincoln Center but you're gonna
get to go
you girls can win it you just made being
a Bella sounds so amazing this won't be
the end of the Bellas there are three
Pitch Perfect movies yes
oh God no no no no that's not well it
looks great
that's really sweet
when my hands aren't covered in in
glitter paint do you think maybe we
could try that again let me know
I that's I will you go blow up Lincoln
Center
that's right
how'd you hear about this place from
yours truly
no way
oh there she is back
you know I realized that I had an app
barking orders and bending people's will
so I made a career out of it
fellas no slouching
great sorrow that I had to watch our
once proud organization become a
National Disgrace you have told lost
your Harmony sure you will be doing
everything together until you regain it
then where are we staying
in sync snore in harmony
we're very close but
I feel like they're about to kiss I know
I don't think
[Laughter]
it out can you sing something
[Music]
oh my God a poop song
I want that song to play every time I go
to the bathroom he was a famous
[Music]
trumpet
I guess those live nodes aren't our
problem anymore guess what isn't a
problem the lymph nodes oh yeah
[Music]
Grown Ups three
rediscovering our sound because it feels
like we're just singing songs that would
never go in our set some
th down but
all his losses coming up she's having a
breakdown I don't want you guys to fight
your Becca and Chloe together your blow
eats and
everything
oh well
done
so legit music producer wants to hear my
word so why would you keep something
like that from us because you're
obsessed you all are this has been my
family for seven years yeah cause you're
too scared to leave
oh this is necessary yeah
oh [__] that was kind of scary yeah that
like jump scare that got me
oh
my team building program
oh my God I'm sorry
I'm sorry I don't actually know which
one of you is which I'm Jessica
[Laughter]
I stick upside down like a bat she said
I sleep upside down like a bat yeah
that's scary that scared me she's scary
you're so good it's intimidating
is to be one of you you are one of us
you pay the registration fee
[Laughter]
to move on to graduate it's really scary
it totally seems that way it actually
does seem yeah
hahaha
underprivileged children how to sing or
I'll dance exotically whatever offers
the most money
[Laughter]
after I graduate there's a chance I will
be deported I will try to re-enter this
country but I will probably die at sea
so let's live for tonight yeah
[Music]
that's a serious issue yeah how about no
one takes her issues seriously no
thank you
I don't know no one knows what she said
okay no she said I just want to travel
through time oh you got it
am I good at that
I got my ticket for the long way around
the cup song
[Music]
this looks awesome
I got the chills yeah what a great
little campfire moment I'd be living
somewhere like sick like Tulsa or a
Little Rock
I'm a professional jelly wrestler for
corporate events
[Music]
[Laughter]
I need to win back my man
[Applause]
[Laughter]
that was well done yeah
whatever
[Laughter]
I don't want to see you
go to her bumper
[Laughter]
[Music]
belong
together
[Music]
go to her he's still upset close your
eyes
the way you did that was so good
[Music]
[Laughter]
I hear your voice inside me I see your
face
[Music]
[Laughter]
there we go bump in the middle of the
night
just skipping their way to a whole
career
yeah I don't like it
what it is is I don't I don't like it
would can do what I can do
you know in a manner of speaking it's
threatening
[Laughter]
he's real for that
my girls are all grown up Sally
does that mean like a lot of them aren't
even in the third one is it like a
different cast yeah they're like old in
the third one right like old women it's
in the future they're like we must come
together
yes singing Kumbaya
does making one last attempt to repair a
damaged Legacy can they do it John
realistically absolutely not those girls
are dead to me
[Laughter]
well you have them as your screen saver
what are you doing here oh yes
you know anything to support the ballots
I love you
I have something for you
oh what way to go guy
you took all of Jesse's screen time yeah
yeah where is he
[Music]
this is cool
oh that's the Pentatonix right there
that was awesome oh [__] good cat Sally
ah
[Applause]
[Music]
there they are that's Pentatonix
that's cool they actually got them at
Cameo yeah I've seen them live they're
incredible
[Music]
also a great song
they do have a great sale yeah that's
that's pretty good imagine having to
watch her competition like before going
on
[Music]
sounds truly electronic
that was a great transition
[Music]
yeah that shit's awesome yeah
yeah one thing it's missing is real fire
why would you watch them that watching
someone else audition for your role and
kill it
oh wow that's good how are they going to
top it if the Bellas of old show up
tonight this could be the most
significant conflict between America and
Germany in history
oh my God
yes we're gonna show them who we are a
bunch of ethnically diverse for the most
part feminine amazing
what are their outfits though Greg
hey it's giving Ellen DeGeneres hey hey
just told Walmart herself they hold on I
can't the suspense don't go out there
invest why are you going out there in
beds
okay
okay now that's cool yeah
they're like playing an advanced version
of patty cake
[Music]
[Applause]
bring it on baby all your friends
[Music]
now this is great
awesome when tomorrow comes
[Music]
is it possible the pardon Bellas are
doing an original song God damn right
um
[Music]
wow that both chills Galore
oh they're like pass Bellas oh is the
mom there
I hope so that's what I was thinking
[Music]
uh they're uniting everyone with their
music America unites everyone
[Music]
yeah
they keep saying it's an original song
but I know this song well it actually
played on the radio after this movie oh
is it from this movie yeah I think so
yeah
nice they didn't want it I
forever and
then nothing weird happens after that
yes every villain was Chris in the house
by sliding down the staircase don't
worry I'll show you
behold
[Music]
uh I don't want to break my neck all
right I'm ready
but I also want to do that
Pitch Perfect
dose to the second
it's suck dick
yes I love him
oh no way
oh my God
[Music]
camping you down
[Applause]
[Music]
[Laughter]
now that's his song right
[Applause]
[Music]
no no why wow I was thinking of John
Legend that's not John Legend
Adam it's Adam Levine and Adam DeVine
that's the joke
his name's Adam DeVine and that's Adam
Levine and they get
[Music]
[Applause]
hell yeah
what's your name brother I don't even
know right now
please just under no circumstances
choose me for your coach you're
interesting and I can work with
interesting
okay you got Christina
[Applause]
[Music]
oh I said hey Amy
oh
yeah they definitely uh
shot that problem
during one of the real shows
more than likely that would be cool
that's so awesome yeah
that's a mid credit scene but yeah that
was the joke like he so his name is Adam
DeVine and he gets mixed up with Adam
Levine
all the time so it was so funny to see
them in something together
I want to see if Pitch Perfect 2 made
money
or Pitch Perfect okay I know a song made
money my God I did hear that song on the
radio the flashlight song
it's perfect one only made 115 million
worldwide
on a budget of 17 million so it did
really well okay it's perfect too holy
[__] Pitch Perfect 2 made 287 million
dollars worldwide off of a 29 million
dollar budget what so the first one was
like a hit and the second one was like a
massive hit damn wow good for them yeah
I mean
for it to be I mean I guess it is based
off a book but still for it to be like
you know I don't think the book had
anything to do with it I
was gonna say for an original idea for
Hollywood that's like very
different like that's a big
accomplishment yeah they they didn't
even double their budget they they went
a little under their budget a lot like
wow yeah they added like 10 more million
dollars and they had way more cameos in
this movie too it was just shocking it's
a cultural
phenomenon Sally
good for them for doing an original idea
instead of remaking something
what a blast hold on we just got waited
out just a couple more minutes okay
I want this to be organized and
structured
get your thoughts in order while we wait
for a post-credits scene these movies
are so fun
they are fun
have you ever seen the movie music
lyrics
no oh is that the uh Hugh Grant movie
yes yeah I've seen I saw that uh when it
first came out
all I remember is the ending
have you seen the movie sing Street my
favorite movies and it's got an amazing
soundtrack I've never seen sing Street
you have to see sing Street
it's so it's such an inspiring movie I
love it so much
I don't know that movie
yeah it's actually really popular in the
I actually heard the soundtrack first
fell in love with the soundtrack
realized it was from a movie watched the
movie and was like Blown Away
it was so good bastards why do I care to
sit through credits show my appreciation
for people all right Sally I'll let you
kick it off kick it off deer do it do
the kicking off
you there hello yeah wait that was a lot
um
it was actually it's so hard to do
sequels and I think this one definitely
delivered it brought everything it could
it was a little slow though for me and
like the
first not first half but like first
quarter or third of it I think some
things were it was like slow I don't
know why but then I feel like once once
I got to the camp you know and we got to
see I forget her name the blonde come
back that was a great moment I feel like
from then on the pacing was great for
some reason like the beginning was a
little slow for me but I think the
yeah I mean I I still I thought this
movie was a I still had a lot of fun
watching it I don't think it's as
focused as the first one is that's a
great it's a great way to put what I was
thinking your focus isn't good because
like you know you're you're gonna get to
the finale uh at the at the at the
concert with the worlds but yeah
um
it didn't
I guess it didn't feel like it it was as
uh important or mattered as much as the
movie would would try to tell you it
does like this I guess the stakes felt
like
bigger in the first movie there was more
of an underdog and because of that
um because yeah they were they were a
little bit divided between like her
music producing career and the other
subplots and our main character cared
more about the music producing side and
then the being part of the Bellas and
and I think because of that even though
the music producing side of the story
ended up uh like as the movie kept going
yeah as the movie went it kept getting
better
um I could see how it's not as strong
but it's still it's still more it's
still really fun I thought like from
beginning to end and everyone still
brought their a game and uh it is it
would be hard to do a sequel to not just
make it repetitive too right and so I
appreciate that they took it in
directions
that allowed for it to be you know like
some familiarity stuff of course some
beats familiar familiar beats but they
didn't tell the same story again and it
was dealing with like moving on and
growing up in like one last hurray even
though there's a third one but you know
like what else uh and and I liked all
the other subplots as well the
the the part and this is where the the
the Divide for Meek would sometimes
happen with some of the music stuff was
in the in the fir I'm talking
specifically about the sound mixing and
and the first one it really felt like
they were
singing in your ears yeah I felt like
they were singing when they were filming
you know look like they were like
pointing a camera and they were just
capturing them while they were singing
yeah this one felt way more produced
yeah it felt like there was record it
was recording and they were like uh
adding it on top of you know I would be
more aware of it this time around
um but then
because of that it allowed you to get
away with some moments that really were
funny and weren't like when Fat Amy is
on the on the canoe and and and she's
singing that was so funny and she's
singing a bumper like that's hilarious
and and it felt real when they were on
stage at the very end it felt real uh
when they were singing around the
campfire like that felt real but some of
the other stuff prior it did feel like
it doesn't it does it doesn't seem as
real anymore I'm aware that this is like
a recording and you're mixing it in now
whereas before I wasn't aware of it
um
but it's still it is still I like don't
get me wrong I still I still really
enjoyed it I still really want to watch
it yeah like yeah I I could say like by
comparison like yeah the first one's a
better movie but but yeah but I still
really thought this was a great time and
and like them thought like ah my girls I
love them you know and I wanna I wanna
watch the third one still I really do so
I wouldn't I wouldn't deny that but yeah
there was
the folk the focus wasn't as um
cohesively as you're right it was kind
of all over the place I feel like uh it
it finally did kind of uh
coalescence towards the end
um and and it found its focus towards
and obviously it had to with the
championship
um you know for me
sequels are always so hard so anytime I
watch a sequel of a hit movie my my
standards and my expectations are
already so low because I know that most
of the time they can never really uh top
the first one unless the second one is
so different that it feels like its own
movie but is still somehow true to the
original sort of like message I guess so
this one there were a lot of repetitive
type moments that they did but they
definitely did a good job of trying to
like make them different in a way like
for example The Sing-Off that they had
in the beginning you're in the first one
you're right like that one it actually
sounded like they were a real acapella a
real acapella groups battling each other
I feel like with this one they
definitely brought it up a notch when
they were at that dude's random party
that whole thing was weird but like also
uh like it didn't make sense but also I
I enjoyed watching it especially with
the Green Bay Packers that that sent me
um but that one definitely like sounded
more like not realistic you know what I
mean but um and then I I don't know a
few things I thought Snoop Dogg would
come back
yeah so that would have been nice I also
think like maybe even kind of make it a
little more cohesive I feel like it
would be cool if there had been like
some sort of scene at the end where like
that song had been a hit and maybe she
got a record deal or like they got a
record deal or something from that
um because I feel like then the
recording studio thing didn't
fully
um makes sense but there was just so
much like uh
conflict I feel like for like no reason
you know what I mean like and sometimes
they're like how can we add conflict and
sometimes the which conflict to care
about like when they were going on the
retreat and saying like we need to go
back in Harmony and stuff
I guess I didn't register that was a
problem until like they did that
performance at the very uh when when
everything went to [__] and people
caught on fire I was like okay I guess
this is
a problem and this is maybe what the
movie should have been about
um yeah yeah that's a good point that's
a good point I feel like the overall
like to me I feel like with what you
were saying and explaining we were kind
of figuring it out because I knew that
there was something kind of like missing
with the story that just like there
wasn't a through line you know what I
mean it was it found it at the end or
like kind of in the middle but it would
have been cool if that was more
established in the beginning that they
just weren't getting along or maybe not
on the same page with things well yeah I
think with with Becca they definitely
try to do that but I feel like everyone
else was stole fine and until it wasn't
and you're like wait what yeah and the
first movie
um like like I think this movie is is
really saved by like it still wears it's
hard on its sleeve and it it still has a
lot of great music and the performances
are still a lot of fun and there's like
I like the development of the
relationship with fat Amy and bumper a
lot um I think Haley Steinfeld is a
really solid addition
um I liked everything with Ben Platt and
Haley Steinfeld that was really that was
really endearing to give him I brought a
lot of heart to it like those two
characters brought a lot of heart to it
yeah um which reminded me of the first
one was Becca and Jesse which Jesse
where were you bro
yeah and I and I think um you know like
the I think the arc for Becca in the
first one is just so much stronger of
someone who she was also like happier in
the first I feel like in this one she
just was like mad the whole time or like
annoyed the whole time you know what I
mean well that's what I mean is it the
the ending competition didn't hold as
much weight because it it felt like our
main character didn't really care
and that's what the hard part about
doing a sequel like this is like yeah
you know you can't go like darker you
can't go bigger and darker with a sequel
like this you and you don't want to just
repeat the plot of the first one they're
already Champions
um so yeah like I can see why I mean I
heard this as I saw in our comments like
people were like it's not as it's not as
strong
um but God damn you know like I I'll
admit though it's still so [__]
Charming to me I still thought it was so
true and I think the cast is still so so
great together and they're they're just
some truly funny moments I I love it
still had yeah it saw some great scenes
it still had some really awesome cameos
that we weren't expecting that on it it
made it feel a little more real like see
you know the all the newscaster Clips in
the beginning and the voice part got me
like
like it was like that the production of
it so well done and I like the I like
the variety of all the performers they
had and as much as they make like
offensive jokes they'd really do do like
a celebration of cultures uh at the very
end which I thought was fun because they
they do a lot of offensive jokes
um yet they they like they're like oh no
we'll really celebrate everyone at the
end though and I thought that was really
touching
um yeah yeah and I don't know uh I don't
know what you do for a third one either
um but because they've done their own
Champion they've done their own like uh
what was that like state competition and
then they did like the country
competition and then now they've done
the world competition so at that point I
I feel like the only thing they could do
then is kind of do a Pentatonix deal
where it's like they got a record deal
and now they have to like tour you know
yeah and that or be a part of a tour
where now they're maybe they're not
gonna get along with other musicians or
other singers on the tour like that's
the only thing I can like think of plot
wise that could be a sequel so
yeah true true
um yeah I mean overall
still had a great time I I I still feel
like the
I don't know I I wouldn't it didn't
really go slow for me it was just a
little bit not as strong a lot of fruit
wasn't as strong for me in the first
half but then yeah things really started
to get better in the last half for me uh
yeah overall and that's not to say the
first half doesn't have like plenty of
moments that I still really enjoyed but
yeah it's not a it's a little a little
it works on Clumsy it kind of stumbly a
little bit though
um a little yeah it wasn't it didn't
flow for me until I would say they can't
the camp part and on like that that
flowed way better than before
um I felt like it was like trying to
find its way and then it found its way I
think he was trying to find its comedy
voice again like well yeah that was the
other thing the comedy for me like the
first one I think is like funnier this
one had diff had funny moments of that
like it was like a different style of
comedy in a lot of areas in this movie
so maybe it was just kind of keeping up
with the times because I feel like
um I don't know what the what was the
gap on these two movies uh I think like
two three years something like that okay
that's not bad but I didn't like their
outfits that's one thing I'm like guys
yeah that for the world comp what you
know what would have been cool though
actually if they didn't win
the world championship
um
but they
but they learned
no I don't know
yeah yeah and
um because yeah like the at the end of
the day is cool it was like the German
guy's music actually sounded they seemed
like they were out of a sketch you know
they were so good in this movie they
were a standout for sure it's like if
the villains the villains technically
like I felt like were were stronger in
this movie well they well I'm a little
bit on a divide there because I feel
like the I feel like for me personally I
feel like the the you know it's like the
ones before they had to be were the um
what are they called the troublemakers
um yeah they had to beat them uh but you
got to know them you know you really got
and they felt like they felt like real
people whereas the I mean I don't know
these were charactery these are these
are the top yeah they were sketches you
know
um they were sketches but they were
still fun and they did seem like they'd
be really hard to beat in fact I'll say
like as much as I liked I like I loved
the last performance by the palace I was
like looks like the German people did
way better obviously I wasn't gonna say
it I wasn't gonna say it I was like is
Greg because that's where I was getting
at I was like it kind of would have been
good if if the Germans won because no it
would have been made a little more sense
um yeah their performance was just so
crazy and awesome and they sound like an
elephant like they really sound like the
instruments you know and and yeah that
was nuts
um but they I mean I really I really
love I I really love the performance
that the Bellas did at the same time I
was like
I don't feel like the other ones really
brought the house down I guess no but I
guess it was like uniting you know true
yeah I don't know but yeah I feel like
it would have been okay if the other one
it's won I don't think it would have
made the ending any less powerful for
the fellas you know yeah like you win uh
you win the respect back of the people
still and you win the respect of the
Germans learn the meaning of friendships
yeah stuff like that nice nice stuff
nice crap like that you know
um but overall yeah I had a great time
um I still I still really wanna I I'm
like I'm dead serious I still really
want to watch a third one like yeah I
just like I like I just like hanging out
with these people you know that's the
thing it's like I like hanging I like
hanging out with them and I like being
in the world and the time passes by
that's probably why they did so well
because people probably like I can
understand why a movie like this people
would go see in theaters because it is
like hanging out with friends uh in an
intimate setting like on a screen
um
it's like the same feeling like you go
to a concert multiple times to see like
the same artist it's because you're kind
of just there hanging out with them and
music's involved and I feel like this
has the same sort of feel as like you go
into a concert and you feel like you
know them because you've watched them
yeah and then and the music Renditions
are always great which is the main thing
you show up for with these but um yes
but you lace it together with a good
enough screenplay and um this this was
solid enough to me I hope Pitch Perfect
3 is better I I wait to see the Rotten
Tomatoes I don't know I feel like it
feels like it would be a really upheaval
battle to do no I I saw a comment that
said the third one was like the worst
one I mean I know I'm nervous
well let's see Pitch Perfect one has an
81 critic score and an 83 audience score
nice Pitch Perfect Two I don't know how
to give that movie like 100
I was like that one's perfect uh Pitch
Perfect Two okay on both ends it's 65
and 64. so definitely went down with
audiences as well
um
I don't want to look up three because I
feel like that'll impact oh you're right
it would influence yeah okay you're
right I won't either I'm gonna avoid
three for now and then wait to wait to
look it up after like I didn't know what
Pitch Perfect 2 was until right now
um but that's good to know either way
alrighty guys well thank you so much for
being here uh still really liked it not
as much as the first one but still
really enjoyed the hell out of it and
I'm excited I'm still excited to watch
Parker because I just love being in this
world it's one of those one of those
first like
there are some franchises where the
first one Remains the best but I still
love the franchise overall you know you
know it just search me as like that kind
of experience
um leave your thoughts down below what
you think of Pitch Perfect Two uh you
can subscribe leave a like and also
follow Sally on her YouTube channel
check out her trailer for The Mary Jane
thing that she has been Mary Jane sure
Phil that she's been working her ass off
on and and the Vlog will be out by the
time this comes out so Greg is in it oh
yes sweet and you are in the Vlog so you
get to see a little if you want to see
Greg for like a split second in the film
go to my channel
a little sneak peek yeah it was massive
someone asked if you if you played Uncle
Ben I could play Uncle Ben
but it was just so funny they were like
is he Uncle Ben
Peter
the great power comes great
responsibility
all right
boom with great shot
prayer
great power
it was great responsibility
you're not my dad a Petro with a good
act of power
create the responsibility I feel like I
feel like the Italian accent's a little
much the New York you need the New York
Italian like I'm walking yo Peter
with great power here comes great
responsibility you son of a [__] yo
all right
we're done okay we're ending this now
all right we have to recast you now it's
done alrighty guys we'll see you all
soon thanks for bearing huh bye
foreign